[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans une petite ville de thuringe en ex
allemagne de l'est de la musique
traditionnelle des saucisses grillées
l'atmosphère est bon enfant
ces gens très ordinaires sont venus
appuyer la f10 l'alternative pour
l'allemagne
le parti d'extrême-gauche stop
mon engagement date de l'ouverture des
frontières
quant à la mère qu'elle les a ouvertes
de manière illégale
je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose de pourri l'accueil d'un million
de migrants en 2015 c'est ce qu'a donné
son envol à ce parti la vie a remporté
près de 25% des voix aux dernières
élections régionales
alès et l'argent va vers la migration de
masse
je suis au conseil municipal et il n'y a
plus de subventions pour rien le pays
est en faillite et je sens de plus en
plus la peur des allemands
moi même j'ai part pour l'avenir de mes
enfants la manière du bon état
la police belge car de l'autre côté de
la rue des opposants de gauche
beaucoup de jeunes venus d'un peu
partout au pays ne veulent pas laisser
toute la place à la mvc terrible pour
nous de voir tant de gens qui tombent
dans le piège
le mépris envers les autres et le
racisme sont tout à coup devenu légitime
on est loin de la grande fête d'il ya 30
ans quand le mur comme liste est tombée
les allemands de l'est se libérer de la
peur d'un état policier
ils pouvaient voyager pensée consommer
[Musique]
franck burckhardt abel avait 36 ans il a
été un des premiers à arriver au poste
frontière bornes en mer il n'en revenait
pas qu'un soldat lui ouvre tout
simplement le gris il y avait marqué au
sol
on l'a enjambé et là on s'est embrassés
et on a dansé à c'était fou mais sa joie
était mêlée de peur car ce jour là les
allemands de l'est ont aussi perdu leur
identité
tout ce qu'ils avaient connu leur
société s'est effondré dire que sera
leur avait à peine 20 ans à l'époque sa
femme dominique en avait douze jackman
le background faudra exact l'un d'eux
s'est soudain c'est au tour du jour au
lendemain les entreprises d'état les
institutions étaient privatisés ou
carrément 10 août
comme des millions d'autres dirk a dû
aller chercher du travail à l'ouest et
il croyait trouver sa place dans le
nouveau pays
jamais je vois que ce futur os l'homme
dont la rda est un pays qui a
complètement disparu c'est comme si tout
le passé rda était finalement effacé
comme s'ils n'avaient en quelque sorte
jamais existé alors que l'allemagne de
l'ouest s'étaient étendus avec ses
institutions politiques avec sa
constitution
avec son économie de marché comme s'ils
s'étaient étendues à l'ensemble de l'est
fink la vie de france dort carte s'est
arrêté en 1989 il a gardé quelques
photos de l'époque mais aussi beaucoup
d'amertume
il a vite perdu son poste d'archiviste
au cinéma l'idéologie marxiste devait
disparaître de la culture lui n'a jamais
su se recycler les films les magazines
les maisons d'édition les chaînes de
télévision tout a été adapté aux normes
de l'ouest au détriment de ce qui se
faisait à l'est et qui avait une
certaine valeur tout d'un coup on a fait
table rase du passé
fang le sentiment de ne pas être
suffisamment reconnu le sentiment de ne
pas être suffisamment présents parmi l
élite du pays est objectivement c'est
vrai que les allemands de l'est sont
beaucoup moins représentées dans les
instances de pouvoir qu'il s'agisse de
l'économie de la politique ou du monde
intellectuel universitaire bazar et son
audace canebière melanie brown
ceux qui se sentent lésés se retrouve de
plus en plus dans live solène roda c'est
lui qu'on est venu entendre
bjorn hockey l'ancien professeur
d'histoire et de sport figure de l' aile
radicale du parti
il vend une allemagne homogène et il
attise la peur en dénonçant les
étrangers à pennetta tirs on l'applaudît
car plusieurs se sentent menacés nous ne
comprennent pas qu'on intègre des
étrangers alors que se sentent laissés
pour l'allemagne pour les allemands pas
pour les criminels qu'on laisse entrer
ici ceux qui violent nos enfants et nos
femmes
les choses doivent changer
et pourtant l'est a fait d'énormes
progrès depuis la réunification
les villes sont en plein essor le
chômage est en baisse
l'ouest a insufflé des milliards d'euros
pour remettre l'économie sur pieds
[Musique]
dirk est d'ailleurs revenu vivre chez
lui à l'est
le coût de la vie est plus bas et avec
sa femme il peut profiter de leurs
terrains communautaires des petits
chalets très prisé dans les anciens pays
communistes
nous sommes une seule allemagne et c'est
ce qu'on veut le passé est important
c'est sûr mais moi je ne veux pas de
frontières invisibles dans ma tête
ils ne voteront jamais pour l'extrême
droite mais des écarts demeurent entre
l'est et l'ouest
et dire que lui se sent toujours comme
un citoyen de seconde zone
ces notes berne ma vie dont le pays a
été complètement absorbé par l'ouest
on se demande encore si on a fait des
erreurs on aurait peut-être pu garder ce
qui était bon vieux temps de la rda mais
parce que ça venait de l'est
on a dit à la poubelle ça n'a pas été
une réunification
on a été annexé par l'ouest
trente ans aux patients à la porte de
brandebourg
l'emblème de l'unité retrouvée les
touristes se prennent en photo au mur
n'y est plus mais pour ceux qui ont payé
le prix de ce grand bouleversement
il existe toujours dans l'été
[Musique]